vuelta a la normalidad aquí en Rusia o
por lo menos la sensación de que lo más
difícil va quedando atrás pero ahora
todas las miradas están puestas
Precisamente en Moscú o en Vladimir
Putin a la espera de qué decisiones
puede tomar si va a reformar la cúpula
militar para destituir o por lo menos
reducir las competencias y el poder de
eternos enemigos de pregosing Como por
ejemplo el ministro de defensa
sergeygu o si por el contrario se va a
tomar su venganza Lo cierto es que el
poder de Vladimir Putin por primera vez
ha sido discutido encima por una
instancia Armada como es por ejemplo el
grupo de mercenarios Wagner tal vez por
eso el poder todavía no se siente
completamente seguro y en algunas
ciudades Como por ejemplo en la propia
capital rusa en Moscú sigue imperando la
alerta terrorista lo que supone que la
policía puede irrumpir en cualquier
momento en las casas Escuchar
conversaciones de hecho sabemos que se
están registrando algunas viviendas
especialmente los sótanos para
asegurarse de que ese conato de golpe de
estado esa rebelión Armada ese motín ha
sido definitivamente anulado